épreuve de la volatilité de la situation
air france annule ses deux vols paris
kiev et kiev paris prévue mardi vladimir
poutine lui président en ce moment un
conseil de défense à moscou et à la
frontière avec l'ukraine et je vous le
disais les signaux sont mauvais d'après
plusieurs sources les troupes russes
auraient quitté leur positions de
réserve on retrouve l ena volochine de
trouvailles spéciale
le signal le plus alarmant qu'on a ici
nous a été signalée par le groupe
conflict intelligence team qui surveille
les manoeuvres militaires russes et qui
a observé ces dernières heures ces
vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux etc
message comme quoi l'artillerie russes
auraient été sortis de ses positions de
réserve ici autour de la frontière pour
se placer en position d'attaquer ce sont
des messages que nous allons pouvoir
aller vérifier très prochainement
puisque nous nous trouvons dans cette
région simplement étant avec les
réfugiés juste avant on n'a pas encore
pu prendre la route pour voir si c'est
réellement le cas des collègues à nous
nous ont signalé et c'est effectivement
ce fait et donc nous allons voir si
c'est vrai ou pas si c'est le cas c'est
un signal effectivement très alarmant
alors que vous le disiez ce matin même
la russie a diffusé ces images d'un soi
disant porte postes frontières russes
qui auraient été bombardés depuis le
côté ukrainien nous avons vu ces images
en l'espèce il s'agit d'un de quelque
chose qui ressemble à un an un hangar au
milieu d'un champ donc une localité non
déterminé un poste non déterminée
personne ne précise de quelle est donc
cette infrastructure qui appartiendrait
au fsb mais ce genre de messages cela
pourrait effectivement servir à
justifier une attaque de la russie alors
même que les sources paramilitaires avec
lesquels je m'entretenais à moscou
évoqué le scénario d'une soi-disant
provocation qui permettraient de
justifier une attaque